the way i like to work is like i like to
go basically wake up obsess over
something go to bed wake up obsessed go
to bed like every second of the day
until i just have a mental breakdown i
burn out and then i like take a day off
or maybe a day and a half off and i like
to go right back to it so i don't like
work certain days i just go as hard as i
can every ounce of my entire body until
i just crash
[Music]
all right in this episode we are going
to talk about one second look we got to
let the guy mr beast actually do the
intro guys in this we're going to teach
you how to make a [__] million
dollars if you don't have a million
dollars we're going to show you in this
pocket all right that was way better
than us yes that's right mr beast the
biggest youtuber in the world joined us
on my first million and husson minhash
one of the biggest comedians in the
world we did a four-person pod
in person this is kind of amazing yeah
so look check this out i think sean
actually mentioned this on the podcast
but about three four weeks ago he said
he's gonna create this thing called camp
mfm so basically he rented a house a big
old mansion in north carolina and he
dm'd like 20 different people a bunch of
different founders and a bunch of
interesting people but then he also dm'd
mr beast and hassan and he told him to
come i didn't actually think they were
going to show up and so we were just
sitting here at night recording a
podcast and they walked in and joined us
and it was amazing yeah it was crazy
seeing one of the biggest youtubers in
the world one of the biggest comedians
of the world they kind of interviewed
each other and they talked about their
creative process what they're
self-conscious of what it's like to work
for them how much they put into each
thing that they do
it was pretty nuts yeah it was i mean it
was amazing they they made fun of me at
first because i was nervous and i was it
was awesome yeah it was a big deal it
was awesome um so check it out i think
you're going to dig it wait hold on
we're rolling we're rolling all right
we're live we're doing it
if it's not recording you're just not
getting it yeah you're not getting it
dude you're not going to jimmy all right
we're live uh wait what are we saying
this is the most interesting crossover
ever yes yeah why are the four of us
sitting here i have no let's put him on
the spot because he seems the most
nervous yeah me
no he's like the body language doctor
yeah he reads body language we're good
right why i'm nervous because i'm
wearing these shorts yeah bro you're
wearing the short shirt we also got a
live audience here why's why what is
this
yeah there's 30 men in this house why
why is there a sausage fest give us
answers this is the power of sean so
listen here's the deal so the story was
is that you wanted to do this and it
happened in three weeks yeah i just hit
up a bunch of people actually you know
what the way it really came together was
i just tweeted it out
because if you do that [__] like you
know just it's like a luck magnet good
things can happen
and a hundred something people signed up
for it
uh scrolling through the names
and it's like what's your twitter handle
and one of them said mr beast
and i was like but but i was like it's a
google form anybody could write mr beast
i was like oh yeah whatever some jackass
then he dm's and he goes this sounds fun
and we don't know each other i don't
know him at all and he's like i was like
oh [__] that was real oh [__] this is on
we're gonna do it now and then i was
like uh he's like where are we doing it
and i was like
where does mr beast live north carolina
i was like yeah we think about doing it
near duke he's like okay i'll come then
and then i got everybody else in after
that you follow him on on twitter well
uh ben from how to take a world like
retweeted him and i was like who's this
guy that i tapped and he just tweeted
like five seconds ago i'm hosting an nba
camp for like entrepreneurs so i was
like oh this looks cool and then i just
that's how crazy yeah i don't know who
this is but i mean basketball sounds
funny and then he calls me last week
he's like
i'm coming but like
i don't know who you are
what's your deal and here we are but you
do that you just walk around and call
people yeah well i just like learning i
mean that's how you did you hear how he
got connected with ben no all right so
ben over here he is our producer and he
hosts this amazing podcast called how to
take over the world and i get how did
you find it
uh well this is gonna get so many levels
someone will put them on you no one has
any idea what we're even talking about
no they do because cliff who's sitting
there told me to listen to how to take
over the world so i listened to it who
retweeted his tweet about the camp and
here i am so you know what's funny about
life story he's like yeah this is dog
[__] content because on youtube you had
to be on point like in the first 10
seconds you needed to like grip people
he's like this is their podcast i've
already gone over 20 ways we could
optimize this better in my head what are
they what would they be let's go already
20 ways well that's what this podcast is
it's a brainstorm we've already switched
topics like five times and we didn't
really hit him with like a hard one at
the start like what would have been
better if it's like i don't know like we
told some crazy story or something like
to hook them or like
or me for the ones who don't know so
then like they're like oh now i know i
should have listened like all right host
the podcast for a second so do our
10-second intro guys in this we're going
to teach you how to make a [__]
million dollars if you don't have a
million dollars we're going to show you
in this pocket like something like that
now they're going to listen all right so
here's what's interesting we got me and
sam
we got husson minhaj who's a famous
comedian netflix special
we haven't announced it yet but yeah
sure
breaking news
we got
jimmy aka mr beast
craziest crossover yeah you guys just
met tonight we met like an hour ago yeah
all right give me first impressions what
do you think of uh mr b he's a cool guy
yeah he seemed really cool what did you
think coming in
i just knew he was a a big like prank
stunt
he's the he's the voice of youtube he's
absolutely
you or he's how you thought he would be
yeah i thought i feel like i feel like
he's gonna get your turn too
i feel like his like curiosity
enthusiasm all that stuff is really cool
yeah i listened to him on rogan he was
really he's really fascinating and what
about you
what was your first impression i mean
kind of the same thing like it was i
mean you were just easy to talk to which
i think was very nice like we were
talking for like an hour yo sean sean
just turned this into indian matchmaking
so fast
so he said something really interesting
to me earlier we were just you and i
were shooting the [__] oh god what is
that and uh
we're uh we're talking about um business
i i think i you said elon musk is like
you i don't know if you said hero but
you're like i think he's like the
pinnacle of entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship yeah sure and i was
like well what what are you what's going
to be your spacex or what's going to be
your like big rocket thing you know and
you said well uh elon had zip two when
he was around my age so zip two was like
his peer filing his peer sharing service
that he sold and made like 20 or 30
million dollars yeah and then he took
that and he did
paypal and then whatever else you did
and you said something like you know i
think i can build like a hundred billion
dollar company but if i'm being modest
i'll build a couple
uh a couple at least billion dollar
companies but but then but and then you
go but i don't really care about the
money i just love winning i just want to
win and i was like yes sounds about
right i'm about this i like that i mean
like money is cool but you know i live
in my studio i don't have like a mansion
i don't drive a lamborghini so it's like
i like money because it can i can hire
more people and grow my business but not
so i can like increase my lifestyle or
whatever so which you know most people
when you say that's why i prefer to say
i love winning because it it kind of
encapsulates it a little bit more
because if if you just like you know
talk about money then people just think
you just want to buy expensive stuff do
your employees
we went to his office today or we went
to his studio and he's like took us on
tour cool this is where we blow [__] up
this is oh this guy's trying to blew me
off by the way
yeah
[Laughter]
but we walked through he's like all
right yeah this is this boardroom this
is my office and so we go in and it's
basically like
imagine like kind of like a gaming chair
computer that's standard next to it just
like two other objects in the room just
take any guess
uh that he had yeah an algae and water
bottle and uh just like
this on the floor a bench press directly
next to the desk
and then the walls were just like
a steve jobs quote an elon quote a steve
jobs quote there was like a timeline
like at this age steve jobs was here at
this agency
you're motivated by that [__] stay
ahead of it also some of those elon
quotes aren't even real i love to just
put fake elon quotes so if people read
it to see if they're like oh that's
inspiring or just completely mine well
they're not that entitled one was just
the one right in front of your desk goes
work super hard
elon musk that's one of the real ones
but i have my assistant like trying to
find the dumbest things elon's ever
publicly said so i can put mixed with
all the real quotes just to see if
people believe them or not were you good
at school like no horrible really awful
yeah yeah that was like i mean i would
act like i was studying but you know i
was filming videos i actually my entire
high school career never brought my book
back home or anything i would just like
throw it under like the bleachers and
then the morning i'd just grab it your
first video was what you were like 12
right yeah oh actually i started making
when i was 11. yeah wow holy [__] yeah
and it's crazy because i see 11 year
olds now they're like this tall and
squeakers and i'm like how was i making
videos
this kid looks
is your first video still live uh no
because i got embarrassed because people
have played in class so i deleted my
channel and then i made a new one when i
was 13. so a little but the 13 year old
videos are still out yeah 13 or so wow
yeah one that's dope that's like a
message to myself in five years uh-huh
uh calling the show you know what he's
talking about so the greatest thing i
ever did in my life is when i was
studying for a history test like back in
a long time ago when i had like 8 000
subscribers i was like screw this i just
closed my book i threw it on the floor
and i just recorded a video i schedule
uploaded a video for six months and i go
hi me in six months i think i'll have a
hundred thousand subscribers whatever or
no ten thousand subscribers i was like
and then i hit stop recording and hit
record high me in a year and i schedule
up because you can upload videos to a
future video year out it's like you
better have a hundred thousand and i was
like hi me in five years bro if you
don't have a million subscribers you're
a [__] idiot uh and i just would talk
to me
five years from now i was just like
talking about the channel but i filmed
it when i had 8 000 subscribers a long
time ago and then i did highly in 10
years blah blah so 10 years hasn't come
out yet behind me in five years came out
my prediction was i'd have a million
subscribers so it goes live on the
channel like two years ago and i had
like 40 million subscribers but in the
video that goes live it's like here's
the date here's the time i'm like a
[__] stupid teenage kid and i'm like
i hope you have at least a million
subscribers and maybe you're doing this
as a job i don't know i make like 10
bucks a month right now like i hope you
can make it a job in the next five years
and that went public and i completely
forgot even did that and i just i was
like oh [__] i opened up youtube and i
saw it everyone thought it was i thought
it was one of the coolest things i ever
did wow and you're like a little kid in
it yeah and so in like three more years
high me in 10 years goes up and i'm like
i remember what's in it it i'm just like
i hope by now you should be out of
college yeah you're definitely out of
college i think that's how i started it
and you should be doing youtube
full-time like there's just no world
you're not after 10 years like you're
probably making a little bit of money i
just hope you are like i hope you didn't
and how much were you at the time
uh like i was that's 8k subs like making
10 bucks a month and so
my prediction in 10 years was like i
hope you're doing this as a job and so
when that goes up i think that's gonna
be crazy and when we were talking today
you like you talk with
a lot of certainty about
like where you're going what you're
doing there's like very like if
everybody's got this knob that's like
doubt
your knobs set to zero on doubt that's
my is that accurate uh yeah well i think
it's we
i don't know we probably spend like 20
30 times longer thinking of ideas than
other people we probably film like 10
times more than other people we probably
spend 100 times for a video more than
other people so it's like we put in the
effort but i don't know how to say where
it's not arrogant i just believe in what
we're doing you know what i mean um back
then like how much do you think you
believed when you when you recorded that
video that that was actually going to oh
no i mean those are just different times
i was in the middle of fun [__] nowhere
north carolina so it's like everyone you
know constantly wanted to remind me
you're not going to be a youtuber grow
up be realistic i think it's amazing
that you never left north carolina
though yeah you're still in bum [__]
nothing about it yeah
do you still rap it really hard uh i
mean i just i got a lot i mean some of
these people over here work there i just
got a lot of people and it's too much to
move what was what was your metric
instead of subscribers and like views
when you were younger because with with
with business it's like revenue or
employees you guys are both business but
you're also like a more creative thing
so what was yours yeah when i was coming
up it was probably
can you do a set on late night can you
do like a conan
yeah could you could you be on i'll be a
um
i'll be a cast member of snl like those
were the metrics kind of
those like legacy media comedy
institutions
i'll be in a movie i want to be in a
sitcom i want to be in a tv show and
what'd it feel like when you started
actually like you know the daily show
and then selling it yeah that felt like
a real like kind of check mark like wow
you've turned the corner didn't you tell
me that yeah that like right before that
happened you were living in a basement i
was living in an attic bro you know yeah
addicts are actually above
sea level but basements are below
sometimes you know so yeah i was living
like a kind of in a not a great
situation though how i'm amazed at your
confidence bro the level of the level of
confidence like the in the video not
just as a sheer amount of confidence you
have because i i still think maybe a
downside of comedy is you have to have
like a very high level uh well comedians
are you self-deprecation and
self-awareness to be like you know what
i mean well you told me something
because i was like trying to be funny
right you sent me these like imessage
things that are like just gold like this
you just sent me these voice notes and
one of the things you would say he was
trying to write he was like trying to do
kind of like a comedy model yeah youtube
video it's up there 17 000 views no big
deal yeah um so but you gave me a little
hit you go get the ego on this man
bro you started right okay i'm at 17
yeah
yeah okay but he says something you go
comedy is low low status game you start
low status
is that a trade secret yeah yeah
you know it's like there's high status
and low status generally if you're low
status
they're gonna empathize with you you
know what i mean so so like what's an
example you get on stage you're being
like i got 17 000 views in front of a
guy who gets like 50 million views and
right but that wasn't it we're gonna but
we're gonna empathize more with you than
we are with mr beast in that scenario
because you're like oh man you know and
if you're if you're like funny about it
and to be confident about
um
that well if you kind of own it people
are like oh like i even just now we did
like an awkward icebreakers of the group
yeah and i was thinking about this
because you know i my prompt was say
your name and say one thing nobody in
the in the room knows about you yeah
which was basically like you can't be
like uh i'm mr beast i make a bunch
youtube videos i'm you know it's like
you can't use your claim to fame you
gotta use something else right and
everybody was saying something
interesting and then i think silly was
the first one was just like i played one
game of little league baseball in my
life because i [__] my pants and they
wouldn't let me come back really great
yeah and there's a little status by the
way that's going to listen to that one
uh but he did a low status one where
everybody else was saying a fun fact
like a cool fact about that totally he
went low
and somebody else was like you know i
remarried my ex-wife which makes me
either the biggest idiot in the world or
i guess the biggest idiot in the world
i still remember that right because he's
like hey group share something no one on
the planet knows no one and then five
minutes later all right podcast here's
what they said yeah yeah yeah i mean
[__] you're [__] your pants that
little league
pretty yeah yeah pretty low status and
then yeah being like all right i double
backed and married my ex-wife again like
yeah like no one knows this jimmy
were you confident as a as a kid in the
career yeah just as a kid uh no i
[__] got off the acne when i was
younger i still have a ton of acne cards
so what are these even worse what are
you not confident about so you're
confident in your work and your ability
to hit certain goals whether you're
actually at least honestly i'm still
trying to get confident speaking in
front of large groups of people which
made me want to ask you a question
because we're talking about stand up
yeah how um
so let's if i dedicated my life to
trying to be a stand-up comic how long
do you think it would take for me to get
good at it
i mean
what's the typical
everybody says it takes you 10 years to
get good but i just think it all depends
on
um
like
your natural capacity and inclination
for it like there's some people i've
seen
when they're open mikers are amazing you
know they just have great stage presence
they have great stories they're amazing
on stage so there's people like that
comics that i met where i'm like the
first time i saw them they were amazing
um gerard carmichael was like that he
was incredible he was just incredible he
was so comfortable we would do open mics
and he would just
everybody was doing was turning left and
he was just turning right like he's just
his his vulnerability his stage presence
people would do their set he would do
things where like
it'd be like a conan showcase and
everyone would do their polished
material like hey what's up i'm hussein
and you know
dating's hard he would just get up and
he would just
off the dome like kind of
do a brand new set that night and you
could tell you could tell you're like oh
this is kind of crazy so how long do you
think it would take him to
get good i don't i mean it's that's like
the question he just asked is like how
long would it take me to because as good
as ariana grande at singing you're like
how would i even
they're like it's not it's not a hack
like
or if you asked if you asked like a mma
fighter like how long would it take me
to get as good as you would like
it's uh oh thank you um it's a
see that's the you put them in low
status you offered the two waters to me
now i feel weird no i gotta put that one
up nah dude low status i spent the whole
life trying to be high
yeah yeah
i have to i have to i have to give mr
beast his water you know what i mean
jimmy what are you what are you doing
you legacy media hack and i just gotta
pour the water for them and they uh yeah
it's just the [__] out of here is your
company ran like a normal company at all
or uh and what would your employees say
about working with you
uh i mean you wanna just come say that
yeah i don't know yeah that's a three
question that's a true question i don't
know
have you had like how did you learn how
to run a company do you ever have did
you hire someone that's what's hard
because like yeah yeah sure he wants
come on in that there's a couple
questions yeah you take over so the
question was like what's it like working
with them oh it's great i mean it's
always different no it really is
always the thing here's the thing here's
the thing
here's the thing here we know it's crazy
like you're fired
i'm fired i'm already fired
like the house gonna answer that but not
well listen
let me ask you a better question all
right so the better question is
what's the
[__] employer what's the like extreme
either extreme good part or extreme bad
part about working with him we know he's
overall extremely actually i will i will
say that right now
so extreme good part is is the
experiences like i've done experiences
that i've never could have imagined in
my entire life like the traveling the
doing the coolest stunts that we've ever
done uh
the the worst part is is i guess
not knowing like what's next in terms of
routine and he knows this best too like
we all kind of go through it if if you
work at mr b so but that comes with it
you know what i mean and that's
something that you kind of have to
accept
um but yeah i think that's my answer
that's right well and the reason i was
asking was because
uh you are your favorite boss i'm a
great person so far 100 percent yeah
i was asking because my employees
sometimes would complain that i'd be
like too aggressive changing things too
much but you seem more aggressive than i
am yeah and for a certain type of person
they like that but for you to achieve
your goals you're gonna have to have a
lot of people and then every once in a
while process and every once in a while
infrastructure and everyone's around
planning are you a perfectionist well of
course yeah um i you know it just
i just like to make the greatest youtube
videos possible and that's that's
literally all i want so yeah i mean if
it's not the greatest video i just want
to upload it it's after you scrap a few
videos we kind of everyone you know just
kind of starts to figure it out does it
scare you that you can't stop do you
ever feel like damn i'm like i'm i'm
just throwing all these coals on the
yeah on the embers of the the algorithm
i like to use better analogy it's like a
treadmill we're on like 12. like full
speed and i've been going out a couple
of years
no it doesn't scare me but so like i was
telling him the way i like to work is
like i like to go basically wake up
obsess over something go to bed wake up
obsessed go to bed like every second of
the day until i just have a mental
breakdown and burn out and then i like
take a day off or maybe a day and a half
off and i like to go right back to it so
i don't like work certain days i just go
as hard as i can every ounce of my
entire body until i just crash and
somehow that's sustainable what's that
what time do you sleep uh right now
usually around three a.m wow yeah and
then and then and then you get up at
like whenever
whenever rohan or one of them knocked
home tariq will wake you up and just
like well yeah people will roll me out
of bed they're like you need to go watch
this video so we can submit it or i need
help with a thumbnail or you got to go
film it's like i don't know i'm kind of
i they tell me what to do i don't think
well i'm just shocked at like the
numbers so like you're the the i'll let
you reveal any numbers but you've some
big numbers for revenue for your other
businesses yeah and
you have to have infrastructure for that
and so that's why i was wondering i was
like because you you are like this oh
gotcha yeah so on the stereotype you're
like this crazy creative person who's
disorganized and that's perfect yeah but
to sell that much of candy and or of uh
burgers like you got to be yeah so those
are all separate entities so for our
snack brand we hired jim who helped
build rx bar and we built the team
around him so that's a whole independent
company that doesn't even work out of
her studio and same thing with beast
burger so that's the beauty i like to
just find people who are just the best
in the goddamn world at their job and
then just empower them and give them
money and so how many people work at the
studio uh
in the studio like 60 because we don't
have enough space to fit everyone so
that's why we're trying to build more
but building things just take forever do
you do people like working for you you
think
[Laughter]
the reason i'm asked is like these like
creative types i'm like
because the goal is to make one of us
like a big deal everyone is working for
that whereas a lot of other companies
it's like no but it's like it's not
necessarily that either there's also
certain
projects where i'd be like i'd love to
learn from you so there's been shows and
movies that i've done like the morning
show like i've never done a sexy
one-hour drama i want to learn from
reese witherspoon i want to learn from
jennifer anderson i want to learn from
the show creators like how do you do
that how do you shoot that what's that
lens what are you doing is that a 50 is
that a 75 how do you did it how did you
do that tracking shot why did you do
that dragon let me see the script let me
see the future script there's all these
things where i'm like i just want to
absorb i just want to see how you
do the whole thing right you know what i
mean like and that's an additive like
positive value for me
because most people don't have that
access to that you know yeah i mean
samples tariq kind of made his idol
today oh man
bro
tariq you got to set the bar
yeah we had told them that you were
coming today to the thing and like the
look of disappointment when they saw it
was i was the only brown guy there
they're like that ain't how they're like
yeah
so you have like a big elon steve jobs
like you admire these guys that's why
you like the how to take over the world
podcast because you like learning from
them what's a story that you heard that
you're like
that like stuck with you like you
remembered you referenced it like kind
of changed the way you were thinking
from those two in particular i think the
biggest thing is like that steve became
a billionaire from pixar you know um not
even apple and so like the fact that he
could go to this just not even hardware
company more creative storytelling
company and just kick ass and create
films like toy story and all these other
bangers um and just just build that
company up to whatever it was like then
disney buy it for 7 billion and
meanwhile apple is just falling to the
ground and about to go out of business
and they you know buy them backward next
and all of a sudden rebounds and
basically the way they did it was just
getting rid of ninety percent of
products and just focusing on like four
or five i mean it just shows like the
power that one individual had even
though both companies had yeah i don't
know a pixar but apple had thousands of
employees and pixar probably had at
least hundreds and despite all that you
know one man can make that much of a
difference like the power of having good
vision and just not relenting is like
invaluable do you think your your
biggest strength is probably your
curiosity
you're down to do anything well so i
think what you have to do is you have to
always be learning right that's how you
can like so like with our ideas right
because we like to do original ideas
that no one's ever done before um and i
might have told you this when we're
talking on the phone thing is like if
there's a hypothetical fruit in japan
that if you eat it makes it where you
can jump 30 feet taller right if that
exists in this world right now you
didn't know it existed so you couldn't
come up with something around that
that's very hyper specific but there's
like a million things like that in the
world that like if you don't know about
it or you're not in taking the
inspiration you can't really come up
with something like if i were to try to
get the stamp like that's how i would
try to do something different i just try
to take and take a bunch of different uh
information and see what spawns in my
head so i try to always be learning
would the mr beast version of stand up
be like i'm gonna do the longest set
ever i'm gonna do the longest comedy set
ever would it have to be would that be
the mr beast like twist on it i would
have to find something different because
obviously whatever is currently out
there yeah because i have a bunch of
people on my team who are stand-ups like
it's been done a bunch of times so we'd
have to figure out something got it
different uh which i would love to one
day just because it seems fun because
you talk to me about all the time but in
general you got to always just be in
taking inspiration from different places
whether it be different podcasts books
or different knowledge i have people
that i pay that just teach me things
just whatever like things that what's
that i think i don't know what what do
you mean by that like they'll just find
things that they don't think i'm aware
of or show me cool things and be like i
don't think you know this is a thing
here read about it and so that way i'm
always like what's an example and how
many how many of these people do you
have this is awesome right now just like
two or three yeah jimmy they call those
people those are teachers
yeah okay i mean he's like he's like
they'll sit me down for about an hour at
a time and what's what's wild is they'll
focus on a subject
yeah like the last one was like uh about
just like crazy online um like which
like these like little things where yeah
they'll upload a file to reddit and then
like inside it's an encrypted code which
takes you to a website which takes you
to a book and like these little like
trace puzzles and like seeing if that
inspired me i know it's just random
i'm black so
in point i'm trying to always expand my
uh knowledge well in my head with new
things that can draw inspiration i was
given him props earlier where i said
so much of people who kind of rev the
algorithm are usually being divisive
they're they're saying something that's
going to make you mad right like i have
a joke where i make fun of mds and do's
and does get really mad and you know
it's like that's like a niche
physician's joke but people get upset
right but while sam was so cool about um
what you do is i think really what
you've tapped into is joy and spectacle
and wonder
which is which is like a counter to that
and it's very rare to see
that really take off on the internet so
what made you feel like i'm gonna do
that versus
do videos that that might that might
agitate people per se yeah well i do
think in general it is a little bit
easier just to piss people off and get
attention for sure a lot harder to do
good and get attention so that's why i
think a lot of people don't but for me
because we just had this ability to go
viral it's just kind of like there's a
world where i make videos and i don't
help people and there's one where i make
videos and i do help people one where i
do help people it's just a little bit
more fun so that's why i do it i don't i
you know pr wise i should have a better
answer but that's kind of the truth
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
what creators do you guys look up to oh
i'm curious to see what you say what
creators do i look up to
youtubers podcasters comedians
podcasters i was going to say creative
yeah it could be it could be anybody
anybody i think one of the first people
that really inspired me i think was
probably steven spielberg really yeah i
mean he's one of the greatest
storytellers ever what was the first
movie that you saw where you're like oh
my god i was blown away for me is
jurassic park um as a kid
i i only watched youtube growing up i've
seen it that's it yeah made fun of all
the time what was the last movie that
you watched uh well i watched the
spider-man 3-1 because but i never saw
the earlier ones really yeah like you
have no time for movies no it's not that
time i just i don't know i i need to
like i need to go back and watch star
wars and harry potter and all that stuff
to get brought up on culture but i was
just like uh you did and so you didn't
see squid game you just did the squid
game
i watched it yeah we did it like i
wouldn't count that as a movie like i
watched a ton of anime but yeah movies
and weirdly enough like growing up i
didn't listen to music or watch movies
so i was like so out of culture
part of i was an introvert there's this
conor mcgregor quote where they're like
you know he was on bbc or something like
oh it's a bigger appearance not just
niche ufc thing yeah what do you think
about this team or this game he's like
he's like you know the uh yeah that one
you said they're great it was like it
was like arsenal yeah
and they're like you don't know anything
about arsenal right he's like he's like
i don't watch the new he's like i don't
watch i don't follow the news i don't
watch sports i don't do anything he goes
i have lost my mind to the game
i am obsessed with my game i have lost
my mind to it
i don't have time for anything else i
don't want to know about anything i was
like
about this game when we were hanging out
i feel like you had that vibe where you
were like
uh you said a couple things you were
like i decided i was going to be a
youtuber and i was going to make great
videos and it didn't matter if i died
the most famous youtuber of all time or
90 years old with a thousand subscribers
i was gonna make great youtube videos
like that's right yeah that's what i
decided i was gonna do
and that's all i do well wake up and i
do that thing what was that first
youtube video that you saw that like
kind of filled you with that wonder
where you're like wow oh well this guy
actually uh got hacked like a very long
time ago this like call of duty youtuber
and they like leaked his earnings and he
had made like a hundred thousand dollars
a year the last few years and i remember
being like 10 and be like what the [__]
they make that kind they make money
doing this and i was just so mind blown
that they actually made money
more than my mom like yeah it was right
there when i was like okay i'm doing
this like i just don't care i'm being a
youtuber or i'm gonna [__] die i just
don't care and that like the second i
saw that was actually possible that's
when i was like that's it and it's funny
also talking about like obsession and
stuff like this because it's funny how
it changes right when you're like and
maybe it's different now because social
media is a little bit cooler but when i
was younger like no one wanted to be a
youtuber like most people when i was 13
14 didn't even have phones yeah like it
was kind of like a little bit of an
older thing and maybe it's just because
where i grew up but it's funny because
back then people are like get alive stop
being a [__] nerd like you're too
obsessive you're weirdo and now it's
like oh bro he was so obsessive he's
it's so great right it's seen as a
positive quality yeah and it's so funny
like looking back on my life going from
a [__] loser nerd who's too obsessive
and won't go anywhere to like damn
that's really inspiring and it's like
damn it was very hurtful back then but
that's inspiring now
and so it's funny to see how it changes
but i like to bring that up because if
there are younger people or parents who
have kids who are obsessive like this
that's typically what happens like
younger kids don't understand that and
it's different and so you don't watch
the newest south park or the newest
movie or whatever so you you don't talk
about the same thing so then people are
just like oh well you know [__] sucks
how would you how would you deal with
that because you have kids i have kids
if they go i want to be a twitch
streamer i want to be a video gamer
you're like let's go i had the same
realization i was like oh so wait a
minute we spend the first 18 years of
our life trying to fit in that's how i
felt in school i was trying to fit in
all the time what what do people do
that's cool how do i do that thing right
and then once i was like in the adult
world it's like oh [__] now we spend our
whole life trying to stand out
like what was all that other [__] why
was i why was i so focused on fitting in
if the rest of your life you're trying
to stand out and i just realized like oh
[__] standing out has been the game the
whole time and the way you stand out is
not by trying to figure it out just like
whatever you're obsessed with just let
that ride because you'll go on a path
that nobody else is going to copy and
then you'll you know you'll land in a
good spot so if my kid like my
daughter's two right now right if she
was into gaming or she was trying to be
a creator all that stuff i would be
all in on it because i know even if
that's not your end game
following your obsession is like the
thing to do in life you know that will
always work out but you know if you like
actually go down that path what most
people do is they hedge
they like this thing but then they see
this path that's more proven or shiny or
they don't know if it's gonna work so
they only half try
right and then it's like that hedge is
actually what gets you it's not that
this career path was that hard it's that
hedging is like you know what was your
major in college biology the ultimate
[Applause]
that was different
well what i think is actually you could
be doing the like
youtube tick tock show i feel like you
can look at his videos and be like all
right i get it i get why people like
this i get why this pops probably pretty
tempting to be like could i go get 50
million views 100 million views that
seems nice no
to do what he's done what he's done he
i'm not gonna i'm not allowed to say you
said you you spent x number of dollars
every video oh yeah electricity i don't
know it started off but you could say
yeah our average news around 1.5 million
dollars i mean that's well
but look at his archive right it's like
he took a plastic knife and tried to cut
a plastic table and it took him 48 hours
to do that yeah that's that's a dollar
fifty video right yeah that's not a one
point five million that's one point five
into a hundred thousand zero it's a
different thing it's a different thing
so that's like a different type of skill
set and muscle so the types of videos
he's producing stand-up is different if
if a musician was here if a dj was here
it's not all the same just because it's
on youtube so yeah we all do different
types of media this is a different type
of media are you tempted to like you
know dabble yeah we talked about this
right i mean
i i the only the the thing that i uh
would be
um
i would be reticent of is
what if i have i have to put this thing
out and i don't believe in it or i'm
just doing it just to do it that's that
would be the problem but i have to put
up a new video every tuesday that's the
just delete the video
what do you do if you if you yeah
sometimes we don't upload for two months
you just only upload when it's a great
video yeah that's all that matters yeah
so i think it's dumb when people stick
to like a schedule and they're like oh
the video is not great but i upload
every tuesday it's like who cares what
are you guys trying to figure out right
now
because i think if you watch a lot of
interviews with people it's like
they it's all buttoned up it's all
figured out they're already successful
it's all working and then the person
who's watching these videos typically
somebody who doesn't have it all figured
out right and they're just sort of like
ah that's different like that'd be nice
to have it all figured out but the
reality is nobody's got it all figured
out right like we were in your office
the whiteboard's full because you're
thinking of new yeah like where are we
going what's not figured out we got to
figure it out so what's on both y'all's
plate of like
what are you still trying to figure out
in your game i'll let you take it first
yeah sean what are you trying to figure
out yeah what are you trying to do yeah
come on sean uh i'm trying to figure out
i'll tell you i'm trying to figure out
if i want to go all in on content
creating
wow like i basically built businesses i
have the most fun doing this but i don't
know if i had the most fun just because
it's a hobby
and like
i you know i only get the good i don't
put all the work in if you love it then
go
i mean it's not going to be less do you
love it i love doing it the way we're
doing it now yeah if i was like him
obsessed every hour of every day trying
to be like how are we going to grow this
channel i might not love it as much did
you like doing the twitter thing
uh for a period of time it got old yeah
yeah you got it it was it was fun to
chase the number can we get 100 000 in
like a few months yeah this is fun to
chase a number but that didn't that yeah
i got sick of it too that didn't last so
that gets me worried but that's the
thing i'm trying to figure out it's like
should i go all in on content creating
or should i stay with creating
businesses which one is like what what
do i want to be when i grow up that's
the question i'm asking myself that
exact same question too because
sometimes like when you're when you're
creating business first and then go to
content i'm like oh man am i just gonna
talk about doing it all the time or am i
just gonna [__] do it yeah so i i
know exactly what you mean yeah i feel
exactly the same way what about you uh
right right now
um
i'm trying to
stay loose for this game tomorrow that's
what i'm trying to do
i'm not trying to get tight man i'm 36
pushing 37 like
he's a young boy like he might run us
off the court
yeah
he was like
tonight yeah
and i was like yo
i'm like dude my l4 is hurting like my
hamstrings are kind of tight from this
flight uh we got to his studio and he
was like uh he's got a hoop there yeah
he's like oh we got we got six let's
play a game yeah he's wearing his like
yeezy slides i was like bro i need 15
minutes of stretching and then like you
know i need like proper medical
attention
here
do you guys want to evolve
if there was an indoor choir we would do
it yeah i played i played 10 1 21 with
jimmy right now yeah okay that'd be a
fun that would be it so that would be a
fun video that would be a fun video you
want to make it happen
yeah let's do it you can just find a
chord somewhere around here
we'll
with your with your answer okay oh what
was the question what's not figured out
what are you trying to figure out and uh
everything so i'm just going to say a
funny joke to change the topic
basketball how to not strain my legs
tomorrow there you go
there we go
[Music]
you